hey guys today is the 30th of November
my name is just and you're watching
games but news first up the EA Star Wars
twitch channel showed off the first
gameplay from star wars battlefront
battle of jakku DLC if you pre-ordered
battlefront you'll get to play the free
DLC tomorrow but if not you'll still get
it free but you'll need to wait an extra
week until december eight the update is
adding a new map which ties into the
upcoming force awakens film and a faulty
player mode called turning point the
publisher are also promising players
more paid and free maps modes and items
down the track you can check out a brand
new gameplay trailer for the battle of
jakku if you missed the live stream
today you probably won't be able to play
THQ's cancelled avengers game in this
lifetime but unseen 64 and did you know
gaming have released footage of the
abandoned action game THQ Australia was
working on the project when they shut
down in 2013 The Avengers game went down
with them although it began as a third
person action game it evolved into a
first-person action adventure with a
focus on co-op the Avengers game was
going to let you play Iron Man Captain
America Hulk Thor Thor while other
members of the super squad would be
unlockable the gameplay was to be built
around team attacks the way you could
rack up combos by combining each heroes
unique ability you can check out the
full video 1 gamespot which reveals a
whole heap of narratives and gameplay
details for the council title miley
documentation from a middleware company
has suggested that sony has unlocked the
ps4 seventh cpu core if this is true it
means Sony is giving developers access
to more of the ps4 CPU resources which
could help with technical performance in
future games buried within the recent
update details for the audio tool earth
mod is a note that reads ps4 added F mod
thread core six to allow access to the
newly unlocked seventh Corps this
suggests the Sony may have made a
back-end change to the ps4 system
software which enables games on the
platform to draw from more
the resources traditionally two of the
system's eight course along with three
point five gigabytes of memory has been
reserved the system operations in
January microsoft began to allow devs to
utilize the xbox one seventh cpu core we
just believed to have aided in the
performance of games release on the
platform since then let me examine that
comment section if you like the look of
the cancelled avengers game and who is
your favorite hero you can add a game
spot we've got stories on Microsoft
talking about the Xbox one elite
controller and a new Mortal Kombat X
character that is everything I have for
you today but be sure to join me same
time tomorrow for a bunch more news